(laughter)
- This is probably going to be
the weirdest video I've been in.
(fast guitar music)
(squeaking)
- I really like peanut butter.
- I love peanut butter. It's
probably my favorite food.
- I just like, I like a good
spoonful of peanut butter
or almond butter for that matter.
- I like creamy, well mixed.
- I never thought I'd be
licking it off some Pyrex
or whatever this is.
I'm really confused.
- Yeah, I definitely don't
think I've ever eaten
this amount of peanut butter
- Wait, how much do we have to eat?
- In one sitting, ever.
- Do we have to eat the whole thing?
(upbeat guitar music)
- So a minute. That's, that's not bad.
Alright, you're going down.
- If I can do it, I'm
going to have Marty join.
I know, what?
(slam, slam)
(beep)
(carnival piano music)
- Ugh, I hate this.
- Aahh...
- Mmm, wasn't bad.
(laughter)
- Oh my god.
- It's all over my nose!
- Can you still bend down?
- Marty's jealous.
(laughter)
- [Kane] I can't do it.
I can't, oh god.
- It's all over my nose.
- (laughter) Oh my god, what are we doing?
- Peanut butter. Go.
(laughter)
- It seriously tastes amazing,
though. You have to say it.
- Ugh. This is so stupid.
- [Off Screen] One minute.
- Oh my god.
- Eww.
- I feel dirty.
(dinging bell)
- Marty, we won!
- Yeah, good job!
- What? Oh (bleep)!
- You're going down, Kane!
(slam, slam)
(beep)
- [Maycie] Oh, God. I
gotta win this again.
(laughter)
(classical music)
- Oh my god, it's so much better.
- Yeah, you have to swallow it, right?
- I'm doing way better than the last time.
- I definitely went
deeper than the last time.
I feel like I did way better.
- I mean, I was just really going for it.
I don't know why, but I kind
of went with like a diagonal.
- Wow!
- Did I do good?
- I'm very impressed with Maycie's work.
(laughter)
- I (bleep) love peanut butter.
- Maycie probably likes peanut
butter more than Marty does.
- [Kane] Yay!
- [Maycie] Yes!
(laughter)
- [Kane] Congrats. High five.
- So can I call myself, like,
Buzzfeed's biggest
peanut butter lover now?
Oh my god, you weren't kidding!
Oh my god, thank you.
It's beautiful.
I'll share it with you.
- Okay, yeah please. Please,
I can't have any for a while.
- This didn't change my
relationship with peanut butter.
We get along really well together.
(upbeat jazz music)
(fly in, squeaking)